as the senate committee discusses that
proposal and comes to a decision Harris
steps into the hallway she then runs
into her in kanan's young son Jason
Jason last appeared in the Star Wars
Rebels two-part finale family reunion
and farewell due to his half-human half
Twilight biology he Sports a striking
head of green hair in his animated debut
which has become one of his defining
features to Star Wars fans thankfully
this detail has carried over into his
live-action introduction but I don't
think the absence of the green tipped
ears and striking eyes will anger fans
one bit during their brief meeting Jason
asked her about Anne sabine's Jedi
training and tells her that he wants to
be a Jedi too this comment prompts a
mildly concerned response from Hera and
reasonably so after all all she wants to
do is secure a safe and happy future for
her and kanan's child just as her
parents wanted for her she doesn't want
him to put a Target on his back by
becoming a Jedi while the Imperial
Remnant gains power however it stands to
reason the force will call to him
someday considering Kanan was his father
it's pretty much inevitable